make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I have been a ridiculously huge
fan of Donnie Cates guardians of the
galaxy honestly I'm a fan of whatever
Donnie Cates writes I mean like his
venom is what really set it off for me I
was like do this is legit but as
guardians of the galaxy run is nuts it's
absolutely amazing so here's the cool
thing
so guardians of the galaxy comes out
directly from like the Thanos legacy
story essentially right where you
learned that like Thanos had a last will
and testament so we covered that story
check that video down in the description
although you really find out is alike
you know after Thanos is death where his
body's destroyed and Ghost Rider pees on
his corpse it's kind of messed up that
that his brother Eero shows up and then
basically like pulls out this you know
giant metal piece from inside Thanos
which contains like his last will and
testament and that's basically where
like this picks up right so I mean this
really the big takeaway from the story
so I guess you know I mean I would watch
it because I think it's kind of
important to know a lot of what goes on
but following that set of events we
basically pick up on you know what used
to be Thanos the ship with regards to
like eros and a whole gathering together
of various people and the reason why is
because eros basically says like Thanos
has a last will Thanos has like a
singular last message for every single
person in existence now it is kind of a
cool little thing here because we
actually have some characters that we
haven't seen for a while we've got
captain universe out here there's also
Wraith who we'll talk about here in a
little bit you've got the starjammers
you've got like you've got a whole host
of people basically like the cosmic
landscape of Marvel remember Gardens of
the galaxy was always a cosmic team so
it makes sense that you would deal with
like you know most of the cosmic
characters who were here in any event
like once this this message is you know
displayed by Thanos then his statement
is okay so like I'm dead if you're
seeing this but it's not the end of me
because what I've done is I've put my
consciousness in somebody and one of you
is going to become the new me piece like
that's basically it that's basically his
last will and testament and it's kind of
a cool thing because what it does is it
literally sends the cosmic community
into disarray because the question
anybody has is well then who is going to
be the new Thanos now the question
becomes you know if that's the case then
who is the new Thanos going to be and
how is he going to manifest himself now
it's kind of a cool moment because
remember nanos is all about seating
chaos right I mean it's really a love
for mistress death and under normal
circumstances we would say it's kind of
out of character for Thanos to just be
like panic for the whole universe but
Thanos kind of loves doing that stuff
right like this is a little bit of
revenge on the whole universe kind of
the legacy he leaves behind is you know
you
my physical form is dead but I'm still
gonna cause all kinds of problems and so
it's kind of a cool little moment
because when you switch over to Peter
quill and Groot they of course we're
traveling out to nowhere so they can get
some drinks and so on and so forth only
to find out that the whole damn thing is
vanished so it's kind of like okay so
this is a little bonkers but again sort
of switching back over to the discussion
between eros and all these guys one of
the things to bear in mind when it comes
to eros is he is the biological brother
of Thanos
but eros was always kind of considered
to be like the weaker version right I
mean Thanos is brute strength
I mean he's super powerful he's got all
kinds of cosmic abilities and then he's
also got like enhancements he's made
using his own modifications and then of
course enhancements were given to him by
mistress death so he's in exceedingly
powerful character eros is a guy who can
emit pheromones basically they get
people to kind of see him in a much
lighter tone and he can kind of get them
to do things that he wants them to do
but what he does is he makes a list and
says these are all the people that
Thanos would most likely upload his
consciousness into based on their own
abilities or powers or so on and so
forth and this is a very important thing
here because this list there's really
kind of Donnie Cates way of saying these
are what phantos considers to be some of
the more formidable people out there
when it comes to it comes with someone
like venom he's insanely deadly because
he's a symbian he can bond himself to
anyone if Thanos were to upload his
consciousness into the Venom symbiote
that he could literally jump from one
host body to the next we can imagine if
Thanos was venom like that would be
crazy you know The Incredible Hulk
that speaks for itself Mephisto that
speaks for itself he's a super powerful
demon entity Ironman his intelligence is
what makes him so dangerous Odin has a
huge amount of power cut Nick Fury
because of the influence he has there's
a lot of people here who are incredibly
dangerous powerful or intelligent or
combination of all three and so because
of that the first thing that arrow says
is these are the most likely candidates
but then there's one who stands above
all its most likely Gamora we have to go
find her and we have to basically kill
her and it's kind of a kind of an
interesting theme because remember
Gamora kind of went rogue during the
events of infinity wars which I kind of
wish the Donaghy's hadn't referenced it
that we would pretend that it never
happened which would really help like
everybody everywhere but because the
fact that he does we have to assume it
did which kind of sucks but nonetheless
you know with with her as a character
because she has essentially gone rogue
she's really just kind of out there and
we don't really know what she's doing
but she is exceedingly deadly and in
fact it makes sense that if Thanos was
going to upload his consciousness into
somebody that it would be Gamora because
she's the one that killed him and so
it's a it's a cool little moment there
but of course in the middle of all this
they're all met by the arrival of like
the head like like no where the head of
the giant celestial ah which in turn
like blows the ship in half everybody
jumps in and starts fighting and then
like they're met with the arrival of the
Black Order now it's interesting that
Donnie Cates does this and in all
honesty I'm not a huge fan of it because
I loved the idea of the Black Order
especially like during you know Jonathan
Hickman's whole Avengers a New Avengers
run the problem with this is that the
Black Order turned it into exactly what
everybody knew they were gonna turn into
or at least people who read comics knew
where they were gonna turn into which is
essentially flunkies and lackeys and
that's it they're just kind of plot
devices and they're there to do things
and no one really focuses on them I mean
there is an actual black order comic but
it's it's I'm not really a huge fan of
it because it doesn't give us an et that
we haven't seen before and he doesn't
really show them is like it's dangerous
as they could be I mean like the ebony
maw is probably the most dangerous
member of the Black Order because he
just talks you into doing things that
you don't want to do doesn't really have
any powers he's just really really good
at like talking to people you know
getting them to do things but
nonetheless you know in the middle of
all this you of course have like Rudy
basically tells Peter quill yeah man we
were kind of invited to that meeting but
like I thought it'd be dumb so I just
didn't tell you because I'm kind of
being a dick in the middle of the battle
Proxima midnight fires this cannon it
opens a black hole and just starts
sucking everything in it's kind of crazy
now of course this basically leads to
like Peter quill and them getting there
at like the nick of time
and when they do like the hammer of beta
ray bill comes out which is attached to
a chain which of course has beta ray
bill attached to it alongside like a
handful of others who he managed to get
ahold of but the numbers are pretty thin
coming for the most part a lot of lives
have been lost we've got moon dragon the
daughter of Drax to destroy her you've
got beta ray bill you've got file of L
who's basically the new quasar cosmic
Ghost Rider and that's basically yet
these are really the only ones that seem
to have seemed to have been saved or
pulled out by my beta ray bill now of
course we also end up finding the reason
why the black orders here is to get the
body of Thanos and then in turn like
bring that body of Thanos
to essentially like the one person who's
seeking it and the one person who can
bring him back hella but this is a very
important thing here for years and years
and years in Marvel Comics hella was
kind of ambiguous in the sense that
people didn't know if she was an aspect
of mr. Steph or if hella was her wholly
unique character and a lot of that goes
into the fact that hella predates
mistress death but then when you had
like basically like a version of death
for the Asgardians and then a version of
death for basically everybody else then
how do you reconcile those two and Donna
Cates doesn't like that what he
basically does as he starts having you
know the the black of the black order
referenced mistress death as a fully
different person
even tell hella not even you can defy
her will it was kind of a cool thing
basically like mistress death is a
wholly different character from hella
seemingly a lot more powerful and the
two of them are gnar not one in the same
at all so it's actually a big moment
that I think when went unnoticed by a
lot of different people but that goes
into the black order basically tracking
down collector and saying where's the
head of Thanos which of course a
collector would have because he would
pay an insane amount of money for
something like that I mean the head of
Thanos is a huge thing for someone like
the collector and so like when he
basically refuses to divulge information
that's when hella shows up and says hey
look like either you can give it to me
or I can kill you now is this kind of a
cool little moment because what this
does is it shows the collector knows who
hella is Riley he's aware of who she is
and that's one of the important things
to bear in mind is that if you're
reading stories in isolation right like
you're only reading Thor or you're only
reading Iron Man or you're only reading
Captain America we're going guardians of
the galaxy you don't really see a lot of
crossover here you kind of see it major
events that's the nature of how those
events function but you don't really see
a lot of crossover outside of that but
if you kind of read all those stories in
their totality it's to say kind of
reading them and you're reading multiple
stories as a singular entity and you
view them that way then what you
basically learn is that there comes a
point when beings approach or or exceed
a level of power that everybody just
kind of knows who they are if for no
other reason than the fact that they're
just so powerful and when you're talking
about a version of death you know
basically like this this you know
Asgardian concept that exists out there
and basically deals with like the realm
of the dead it would make sense that
with that level of power would also calm
like recognition as it was kind of a
cool little moment here because then
following that what you basically do is
you pick up with eros and and end
gladiator in these guys who somehow
managed to survive this whole you know
crazy ordeal inside this black hole and
then in turn like they're met with the
arrival of wraiths now Wraith is a
character that we have never talked
about in Marvel Comics and the reason
why is because we never had a reason to
but I mean there's never really a reason
to talk about the character of Wraith
but what Donnie Cates does here is
actually tie him into the greater
universe the way this worked originally
when Ray's first popped up it's he's
part of a group called the nameless and
all that means is that somewhere along
the line a handful of creeks were
essentially just kind of like yanked
into a different dimension that was home
to like these weird little parasitic
organisms that would latch on to you and
then basically start consuming your soul
but in return for that they would
basically give you like immortality and
an ability to feel pain like an insane
healing factor might be super strength
and speed and all that kind of cool
stuff they would enhance you and in base
they make you more powerful than you
were before and they would enhance you
based on what powers you hack fry so
like if you're a creep you become more
how a more powerful version of a creep
and then following that he just kind of
showed up and then did some things and
had some cool moments you know during
anihilation but again he was never
supremely interesting in this what is
cool about this is Donny capes changes
all that
and what donny kate says is that the the
nameless like these these little
parasites that exists out there or
actually were actually created by nola
symbiote god and so what this basically
means is that like the function and form
of wraith is a byproduct of Nowell the
symbiote God and what wraith is looking
to do is basically find information that
can allow him to either reverse the
process or somehow defeat null or get
ahold of him or whatever the case is to
essentially like go back to the way he
was before to escape this fate that's
been bestowed upon him so it's a really
cool way to take what is my all
standards of measurement and exceedingly
obscure character
roll him larger into the to the Marvel
Universe and then in turn like go
forward from there but of course this
leads to to nebula basically speaking up
and and of course addressing the crowd
and saying hey look we don't know where
Kimura is nobody knows where Kimura is
save for one person and it's the one
person she only ever really loved does
she ever really gave her heart to which
of course those of you guys who are
familiar with Marvel's history you guys
know this is none other than Richard
Rider and it is good to see him return
Richard Rider I have missed you buddy
it's been a little while yes you
returned during the Nova comics and yes
there were some cool moments but it just
wasn't the same it's cool to see Richard
Ryder come back I actually kind of dig
this but of course you know what the
collector basically telling a hella and
her forces that the head of Thanos was
uh sold to the negative zone they end up
travelling there and come into contact
with a nihilist now hell is showing up
here this is kind of an important thing
he'll is showing up here and then
basically just like kind of running off
to Annihilus and and causing problems
form is actually a gamble and that's one
of the ways that that Annihilus works
right I mean Annihilus can be
intimidating he's very very powerful
with the cosmic control rod which is
essentially the negative zone version of
the power cosmic to power the Galactus
wields but he can still be intimidated
and her showing up here and basically
saying hey look like you know give me
what I want or I will kill you and
instilling fear in him in that regard he
ends up doing what she wants and ends up
giving him or giving her the head of
tano's but the reality is that if he
really channeled the full totality of
the cosmic control rod he could kill
hella here he could destroy her and
that's one of the cool things is
basically like he doesn't call her Bluff
you know I mean
she's able to injure him and damage him
but like at the same time he could wipe
her out in her entirety but basically he
succumbs to like being blocked but of
course this leads to Richard rider being
tracked down and chased down by
gladiator and really the forces of eros
and then of course you know it leads to
race showing up and saying hey look give
me the location of gomorrah or I'll do
like terrible things to you and it's
really more of like an intimidation
factor but then you have cause you have
cosmic Ghost Rider who steps in and you
never really see this part of him that's
why I'm glad the Donnie case is riding
this because you can really kind of
build on and expand on the characters
that he essentially created and so with
that happening
cosmic ghost riders like look man like
the problem that we have here is we have
Gamora running around who kicked off the
entire last infinity saga so we know
that she has no limit to the lane she'll
go to to achieve a goal that she
believes is right she killed Peter quill
she's basically Thanos so like we have
to take her out we have to eliminate her
because she's essentially gone rogue
she's a pillar and the responsive
Richard Rider is no and he essentially
races off and leaves and it's kind of a
funny thing because where everybody
seems to kind of look at that and say
well we're sort of screwed now we have
no idea where he's gonna go I mean yes
he's cut off from his own Nova Corps uh
but we have no idea where he's gonna go
the responses of nebula is that's
because you're all idiots like he's cut
off from his own nether from his own
Nova Corps he's bleeding out he's
injured where do you think he's gonna go
to he's gonna go to the only place that
he feels safe he's gonna go to Gamora
and that's exactly what he does it's a
cool little moment and it's a cool
segment here because it's a great way
for Donnie Cates to her to really kind
of throw back and that's that's what
this reminds me of it reminds me of like
Dan Abbott's whole like cosmic run on
like annihilation annihilation conquest
war of Kings realm of kings all those
things that whole you know cosmic scope
of Marvel that he essentially put
together right I mean you had like Jim
stone and those guys in the old school
comic fans you know they're really the
rules you know there's ol the old-school
hipster guys would be like well no it
was all jim Starlin not really jim
Starlin kind of created like some
characters and like sort of tolls of
cosmic stories but the work that jim
Starlin did was dwarfed by the work that
dan hadn't it did in terms of like all
the cosmic scope because he brought it
all together and made it all cohesive
and organized so it's it's it was pretty
awesome like it was it was it was really
really cool nothing like of course with
the forces of you know Peter Peter cruel
and all those guys basically realizing
that look amor is done is she's showing
up to the world a rocky raccoon seems to
be at they end up figuring out where
she's at in their own way and of course
gladiator and those guys will track up
will track Richard Rider this leads to a
fight between Gamora and the forces of
Peter
which include like beta ray bill in
these guys now here's an important thing
to keep in mind can gomorrah go
toe-to-toe with beta ray bill and defeat
him through conventional means no what
makes her cool about this what makes it
so interesting is the fact that what she
lacked in strength and the ability to
like defeat him she gains in like her
intuitive tactics and her ability to use
like military strategy to her side and
so when beta ray bill throws his hammer
and officially ends up catching her
off-guard this in turn leads her to like
attach bombs to it so that when he
summons it back then it'll blow up in
his hand now she does that because she's
similar with Thor like it's things like
that that make her so dangerous and make
her so capable her quick wit thinking on
the spot there's also leads to like
Rocket Raccoon kind of peeking out and
watching everything unfold uh what's
going on with Rocket Raccoon we'll find
out but I'm not gonna tell you in this
video so I know a lot of people are kind
of like boo this spoo hiss but of course
this leads to to Richard riders showing
up I kind of crashed landing inside the
ship in saying hey like we have to go
find Gamora uh and then realizing she's
already there within calling Peter cool
an idiot because what this does this is
gonna lead to like a full-scale fight
between the forces of of eros and the
forces of the Guardians and so you're
talking about some pretty heavy hitters
here some very powerful guys among them
race gladiator vile of El Mundo aegon
like you're talking about some pretty
heavy hitters any one of which could
show up on earth and give the Avengers a
run for their money if not take them out
entirely and in fact like moon dragons
done that before you're talking about
some very very heavy hitters some very
powerful guys here now of course this
leads to like to take a more of
basically bringing yourself free after
she was kind of locked in a room you
know putting timeout by Peter quill more
or less but of course when that happens
and like a shot is launched off you end
up having Peter quill who jumps in the
way at the blast and seems to sacrifice
himself for Gamora and so following that
gamora's taken by gladiator and the
Shiar of the Imperial Guard and the
forces of eros and then of course all
you have left of the Guardians and
everybody's kind like oh my god Peter
Quill's dead no he's dead and Bruce like
no no he's just out like we could wake
him up and so like one of grits little
stabby guys runs up on him can we also
just say the little stabbed e's like
like little pieces of Groot like break
off and like become like little groups
there's just like run around with knives
and stab people that's amazing right
like like I am stabby dude I love that
like these little brutes by these these
little mini groups that are just like
running around and stabbing the hell out
of people it's pretty awesome like it's
actually pretty cool
but of course when the questions asked
how are we going to find Gamora then of
course you have beta ray bill who
basically responds by saying we'll call
in a bloodhound
now this is actually a really important
and a cool little theme that comes out
of this so one of the things that came
out of definitely in humans is that we
actually ended up learning that beta ray
bill and lockjaw had like a lot of
adventures from back in the day right we
didn't know about that I mean they
presumably have an off panel but he was
just kind of introduced in like hey like
yeah like me and lockjaw like we had a
whole bunch of adventures like it was a
cool little thing I feel like we need
those comics right like I feel like we
need like like beta ray bill in route
like we need that you know who knows
what adventures bill
lockjaw invite you like we need that
like we really really need like we need
that comic and I feel like Donny case
needs to write it because I feel like
you I feel like gonna be the most fun
ever like it'd be pretty it'd be pretty
sweet to see but what you end up having
of course is Gamora who's basically
brought before eros and again the idea
is we have to kill her because she's the
most likely host for it for Thanos new
form and then you have hella who shows
up along with the Black Order who take
out gladiator literally like stabbed him
through the chest take out gladiator she
totally takes out a cosmic ghostwriter
literally just like eliminates Mephisto
his hold on him which is actually kind
of cool because now this puts hella on
par with Mephisto in terms of the power
of the she possesses so basically uh
helic hills cosmic Ghost Rider then you
have like her basically spilling the
beans to everyone and essentially saying
hey look uh you guys are all idiots
there was ever any host body for Thanos
why would fans put himself in anybody's
hosts like anybody's body if Thanos is
going to come back Dallas is going to
come back as himself
Dennis would never lower himself to the
point where he would return in somebody
else's form and if he did it would only
ever be temporary and so what she says
is okay yes like there is a kind of
backup there and it's actually in the
mind of eros but he's not gonna stay in
your body he's gonna go back into his
own body and so literally Thanos wakes
up in the body of eros and then from
there begins a process of transferring
his consciousness into his old physical
form and trying to bring himself back
and is actually pretty badass because
this is essentially the return of Thanos
and so with with him you know with these
guys being whisked away now you've got
like what's left of the forces of eros
who basically realized they'd been
tricked you've got the forces of the
guardians of the galaxy all of whom
joined together and then they in turn
race off over to hella and then like all
hell starts breaking loose but it's kind
of a funny thing because you've got
cosmic Ghost Rider who's there and he
starts talking to a Peter quill saying
hey look I can't hold my body together
I'm basically falling apart
this is where I die and then he perishes
only to be transferred to hell and to
meet Johnny Blaze and this is badass
dude is one of the coolest
ever and so from there like like a more
of the guardians and so on and so forth
ah they all actually end up take out
eros like a more kills eros
like that no questions asked because
she's just like if he's the host body
for Thanos kill him and be done with it
and what this does is it cuts the
transfers short and so basically if
Thanos kind of returns but like in this
kind of garbled nonsensical state not
fully himself and then just is just sort
of there so basically he comes back he's
like a half-measure
and I was kind of cool because what it
would do is almost given this give us
this kind of like psychotic savage Hulk
version of Thanos which would be badass
to see the problem is we don't see it
because in the middle of all this you
end up having like like hella who goes
crazy it fires off like this cannon
intense so like take out beta ray bill
beta ray bill like knocks it you know
knocks this giant bullet thing ends up
like impaling Thanos it kills him and
then like it opens up a black hole
basically the gun of the gun of Proxima
midnight and so Thanos is like sucked
inside of his own black hole he's
basically gone his returns essentially
stopped so at the moment Thanos is not
coming back it's kind of a cool little
thing but at the same time it's kind of
disappointing because I always wanted
fails to make his return like I always
wanted Stannis to come back because he's
such an immutable and in like he's
almost like a universal constant right
like a necessity he's always been around
and he's actually one of the more
interesting villains and Marvel Comics
and so with that happening with the day
more or less being safe on Peter quill
brings together what's left for the
guardians of the galaxy so you got Groot
beta ray bill moon dragon you've got
file avail Gamora you've got lockjaw and
then the questions asked but like what
about rocket racoon though so of course
now they're on a mission to go find
Rocket Raccoon but that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]